- Over the last five years,
forget about even the election,
the enormous minority of
unhappy people in our society
are dramatically louder
and are impacting us more
than the far majority of us
that are happy and good.
There's only so much that
I can do about being happy
and documenting
my happy journey.
I'm trying to pressure
the other people
that are happy
to talk about it too.
I just think we're in
a very awkward time.
I think it's rubbernecking and
it's just the way it is, right?
We pay more attention to
the negative than the positive.
It's just how I feel
about the world.
I think human beings are the
most underrated
thing of all time.
When I think about our
capabilities to
eliminate each other,
I'm being serious, I know
it's a kinda weird place to go,
but the fact
that we're still here
we are hard-wired
in a way that allows us
to protect each
other in a net game
yet the mainstream media
and the way we hear
all you hear is negativity.
All that mainstream media
does is tell us about the
.0001% worst of us.
I think we as humans
are going to have some level
of a sense of responsibility
that if you're in a good
place it might be good to
tweet or Instagram or
Snapchat about that versus
what we default into
which is there are people's
Twitter feeds that are basically
every seven or ten days
when they're
complaining about an airline
or venting about work.
The volume of negativity
is just way too high
in reality of what's going on
and I think the silent majority
of us, and this is what happens,
every empire falls when the
silent majority of
happy isn't loud enough.
(somber music)